donc ici on a un grand frêne alors là
c'est dommage parce que je suis pas un
somme au centre de formation pour
adultes de quétigny ici on forme des
paysagistes des maraîchers et des
horticulteurs des métiers mal connu la
visite ce matin là vise donc à les faire
découvrir ainsi que l'établissement et
son parc
vous connaissez peut-être les orchidées
orties horticole là vous voyez que c'est
quand même c'est quand même un peu
différent pour la direction
l'établissement c'est aussi
l'opportunité de montrer l'agriculture
en dehors des clichés on est sur des
métiers qui ont énormément bouger les
gens mesure pas à quel point on a
partout des exploitants des
horticulteurs des paysagistes qui sont
dans la qui sont dans la réflexion qui
essayent qui expérimentent et celle
avantages du parc c'est qui nous permet
de montrer ce qui a été fait il ya 50
ans et comme ce qu'on a fait cette année
où ce qui est en train de se en train de
se réaliser lancereau mais là c'est le
domaine expérimentale de l'inra de
bretenière sur ces 120 hectares ou
testent de nouvelles techniques
culturales qui permettrait de ne plus
utiliser aucun produit phytosanitaire
donc on a des outils de désherbage
mécanique et l'agriculture de demain
c'est justement ce qui intéresse cette
visiteuse
on entend beaucoup parler d'écologie de
pesticides
de tout ce qui peut nuire à la santé et
là c'est un site agro écologique donc on
peut estimer que et on le voi avec les
insectes qui a pas d'utilisation de
pesticides donc ça m'intéressait de
venir voir comment ça se passait dans la
vraie vie pour l'ouverture de cette
première édition des journées de
l'agriculture le public n'était pas au
rendez vous mais l'initiative est
heureuse estiment les participants qui
rêvent même d'aller plus loin
c'est extrêmement important que ces
journées nationales de l'agriculture
existent qu'elles n'attirent
progressivement peut-être son format de
l'école de la fête de la musique si ça
c'est si ça serait est dit et bien que
ça devienne une grande fête populaire où
on découvre finalement le monde de
l'agriculture et que ça ça transforme
l'image de l'agriculture dans la tête
des gens et pour cela de nombreuses
exploitations vous attendent jusqu'à
dimanche soir